it's very natural in my in my experience
at least
to feel like the dumbest person in the
room when
immediately after acquisition because
everyone has the experience of the
previous years
and you're coming in okay
[Music]
all right ron diamond thank you so much
for joining me on 20 minute leaders
gladly i'm happy to be here all right i
cannot wait to learn over these next 20
minutes or so about
leadership and tech about what it's like
being a a very very very early employee
uh like you were at on apora and you
know your your incredible experiences
being a tech lead at various very
well-known companies i think most
recently
aws right within amazon so
let's dive in ron tell me a little bit
about who you are take me all the way
back to your time at the technion
you're doing your bachelors and masters
and let's go from there
all right cool so yeah i did i was in
academic reserve i
did my bachelor's in electrical
engineering in the technion
after that i went to the military worked
as an engineer for a couple of years
during that time i did my masters as
well i actually studied a lot
in the in my military service i enjoyed
it quite a lot i know that many academic
academic research don't like that time
so much but i enjoyed it
after that i went after the military
service i went to work for an israeli
company called zoran
a semiconductor company where i was
doing mostly math
stuff so kind of an intersection of
mathematics and engineering so error
correction codes
security applications and all
all things that are kind of math related
after a while zoran got acquired by
csr a british company and with that i
found myself moving to a startup that
was in
the very early days if i record
correctly i was employee number seven
there
wow startup was a sports and aponomous
after about four years an emperor got
acquired by aws
which was interesting especially with my
previous acquisition
experience which wasn't that positive
but but that acquisition with aws was
actually quite amazing aws
is a great technology playground and we
can talk about that a little bit
um and since then since then i'm in aws
i actually
got the chance to initiate the product
for aws a
machine learning related and maybe we
can talk about it later as well
incredible did they disclose the the
deal
of the acquisition for anapura there is
enough information online yeah enough
information online so i'm gonna have to
attach it afterwards
in the top but but you know i have to
ask uh i have to ask
what is it like being a very early
employee at a place like anapura
and what i mean that's a very different
experience from being
a founder of the company you've
essentially been in the same room as
them
practically from the very very very
first days yet you had very different
experiences so talk to me a little bit
about what's it like being
a very imp very early employee yes
probably
highly highly recommended especially if
you're joining
a founding team that is experienced
and and know what they're doing it's a
great experience
um so i would say it's scary at the
beginning
yeah it's scary because you take your
you typically reduce your salary a
little bit
you join a team that you don't know how
things will play out with
you don't have a defined role you do
whatever is needed right
but it's a blast i mean you you
instead of being very focused in one of
the big companies like
i won't mention other companies names
actually but uh
but instead of being very focused on
your day job you get to do
whatever task is needed at the time and
if you
if you are willing to go out of your
comfort zone you go out of your comfort
zone all the time
so i was hired to do one thing i think i
did everything else in the company other
than the thing i was hired to do
um i learned a lot during these years
i learned a lot from the founders who
were these guys were experienced they
were the keys in marvel
prior to founding an important logs um
all in all i think it was a blast you
and
one thing that they keep telling other
folks is that what's different between a
startup
and a big company that is that when
you're in a startup
everyone wants for everyone else to
succeed because you succeed and fail
together
and in a big company that's not exactly
the vibe that you're getting and the
entire day-to-day becomes completely
different once once a
you work as a team and try to fix it
incredible so how long did you spend at
anapura as employee number seven
uh so an opponent grew very quickly i i
spent four years in an opponent from
joining until we got acquired
uh but an opponent grew from seven
to about 25 in a matter
of six months wow and from there in the
next two to three years we grew to 120
and today we're way more than that but i
cannot disclose the number because it's
internal data
wow incredible okay and and so at the
end you're saying on one hand
you join an early stage startup you it's
a lot it's
you know a lot of fun you're a part of
the team it's on it's not really defined
it's not structured so you get
it's like a big playground and you get
to be a part of hopefully a very nice
success story
like like the acquisition to aws but
the alternative the drawback is that
it's more risky you usually take a pay
cut
for that potential you know milestone
later on right
absolutely but what i would recommend
for for junior engineers is to not think
about the short-term salary
or compensation think about the
long-term just the
the amount that you will learn in a
small company as a
startup is way higher than
what you will learn in a bitcoin right
definitely but then i mean
you can't just go and it's it almost
seems irresponsible to just go and join
any
early stage starter because it seems
exciting i mean then you do want some
stability
and a lot of early stage startups today
i mean they're they don't
automatically offer you compensation so
what are your tips on sort of
you know balancing the two ideas and
what type of due diligence can you do
on an early stage company before joining
so
my i don't know if i have a very a well
thought set of tips but i can tell about
myself i wanna i wanna know your
experience
yeah so uh what i did is i i started
when when zoran got acquired i figured
that this is not going in the right
direction and that's one recommendation
that i can give
don't look only at your day-to-day think
about where the company is going
long-term right
once i saw that this is not going in the
right direction i started looking and i
was
pretty pretty young i wanted to
experience a startup
so i one of the things that i started
doing is to look at startups that are
out there today
and i was just looking at the newspaper
asking folks around
uh when i all of a sudden heard about an
appointment
what excited me there uh is first of all
they were in
very early days i think they were in the
one month
after being founded wow the second thing
that i
noted immediately is that the founders
were a folks
with a significant experience and very
well established record
right that was that was a good sign for
me and the
in the third thing that i noticed is
that the the
bond sorry the the chairman of the board
the person that gave them the seed money
was a well well-known person in the
semi-conductor industry
okay victor villans and i want to and
he has a record of founding companies
that eventually
become successful wonderful these were
good signs for me i also
went and talked with my dad and i didn't
work in the field
and he knew all these folks and said
thumbs up for me i know these guys these
guys know what they're doing go for it
and
i love it i love it okay at the end
that's the most important advice talk to
dad
they know they they have the best advice
in the end is from experience
but ron then you transition to aws so
now you're a part of a much larger
organization and it's no longer you know
you're no longer just employee number
seven
but you and and while you may be leading
your own product within aws
i mean you're still part of a new
culture you have to adapt and assimilate
into a whole new you know type of
company so how how is that
progression like and what are some of
the challenges that go with it
so first of all immediately after
acquisition you have a big stock because
all of a sudden there's all this
terminology in terminology and
culture that you're not familiar with
right and you're starting to study
quite a lot and and basically coming up
to speed very quickly
um you it's very natural
in my in my experience at least to feel
like the dumbest
person in the room when immediately
after acquisition because everyone has
the experience of the previous years
and you're coming in completely friends
uh
what i would recommend is first of all
learn learn as quickly and as much as
you can
but on the other hand don't take things
a
without applying some judgment so there
were things that i liked about the aws
culture there were things that they
didn't like about aws culture
and i think it was the correct thing for
me at least
to to integrate with this with the stuff
that i that i
would connect with and not blindly go
with everything that i saw
and be patient at the end of the day you
need to know the people you need to know
the technology and
you need to know the history and then
you can function totally okay so
let's move on to this idea of team
execution lean execution
and and what makes or breaks a good team
and
not just about whether people like each
other or whether they have a good time
in the office but also about
actually executing products because
you've seen the good and the bad so talk
to me a little bit about
what are some of the key takeaways of a
good engineering team
so i think a lot of it is about
ownership so what i see
in different teams is when people
own things from beginning to end things
tend to converge
uh much more smoothly uh so what i see
in many things that are not delivering
very quickly is that everyone has their
role
and they're they're doing what they're
asked to do and
that's it they stop with uh they stop
the responsibility there they don't
continue to check with the next person
in line
whether they got everything that they
needed whether it's working for them and
so on
uh one thing that i like to do is first
of all make sure that people
that are working on a product
own this product from a to z even things
that they don't do themselves
um and it takes some iterating with
people to get into that mentality
but when people do it first of all it's
way more fun because you
don't just execute on tasks you
basically
own the entire product you feel like the
product is yours that's a big advantage
and the other thing that you see is that
there are way less miscommunication
because when
people are a people are not just a
building a product to a certain
specification but rather
actually speaking with their customer
whether it's local in the team or
another team and
understanding their needs understanding
whether the product that they receive
actually meets their goals and so on and
and that makes a huge difference that i
would say that's my number one
my number two and that's probably a
debatable
but i don't believe in a overly document
i think projects moves fast you don't
know everything in the beginning of the
project
if you try to document every decision
that you are going to make
and then you try to execute that to that
specification
by the time you you start executing the
entire specification become became
irrelevant because the industry is
moving forward so that's about the
the lean part of it right exactly so so
i strongly believe in doing
50 of the specification work working
based on
gut feel and understanding of the
overall direction but starting to
execute
while keeping on iterating and closing
but is that
is that feasible within a large
organization like aws when you
inevitably you have you have these best
practices and conventions in place
because you have to align you know
thousands of engineers
it's visible but you need to be clever
about it so i think
you don't always say hey listen i have
50 of the products specified go execute
that that doesn't work
but you you say okay i have a
specification here's a specification and
you make sure
that a team starts to execute with the
portion
of the specification that you actually
have high confidence in
and as and and you also do communicate
that there are some
unknowns that you're still working on
but as long as you
close the unknowns before they get to
executing it they think that
it's cool definitely so how many of
these how many different
teams and products would you say that
you've worked on over the years
that's a good question i i would say
roughly six or seven
chips that i worked on wow um and
they all are very similar and very
different from each other so it's a it's
an interesting
thing to ponder i'm sure and then so
what's the role of the leader
of of an organization a small
organization that
needs to execute on a product so fine so
you have
you know the engineers are you know
they're working they're lean their
documents you're not documenting but
what's the role of the team lead
or the technical leader of such a
product so i think
uh first of all the the technical leader
or the team leader if everyone sees them
as a leader they already
made a mistake uh they they need to
drive the culture
where decisions are made in a
distributed manner
okay every single decision gets
escalated up and you already
the team doesn't scale you already make
the second thing
in my mind is to drive the culture of
the team uh first of all
second being very focused on execution
so one thing that happens in many
engineering organizations
is endless debates on the best way to do
things
i think you need to draw the culture in
the theme where
you you spend your time on what actually
matters
and if there are a couple of decisions
that will move the needles
needed by one percent just make a
decision move on even if it's the wrong
decision no big deal
the third thing uh i would say is
constant prioritization and
communication across the team
so a project is complex you don't know
exactly what
what you're getting into at the
beginning of the project so there's no
way you can prioritize all the tasks
for the next year and a half and i'm
talking cheap products that take a year
and a half to execute
you cannot prioritize the entire thing
in
day one so you need to constantly go in
and prioritize
especially because as the chip as the
project
nears an end you're going to give up on
some features
so it's better that this will be the
last important features
um and interestingly endless right
communication across the team i think is
also key making sure that people
actually understand
so that they make the right decision in
their every day
so i spend i i guess 30 of my
time just explaining things to every
single engineer that is willing to
listen
because i think eventually
it's worth it people make better
decisions do you
so this idea of foregoing some features
and
and leaving and and you know deferring
the the least important ones to the end
this prioritization
i mean then if that's one of the hardest
things i think to do especially as a
team leader right you have
you have the product of the product
specifications but you have all these
conflicting notions of what's important
what's critical what's not critical
and a lot of that is also you know not
just about the product
requirement but it's about the actual
implementation of the product
and whether you want to go the extra
mile implement it better
or do you want to release it you know
free sprints ahead of time
yeah so i think the more i i feel with
time that the more educated i am and the
more
time i spend into looking into every
point of the project
the easier it is for me to prioritize so
at the beginning
i would always almost feel like i'm
improvising and it's really tough to
make the decision
uh but if i look in retrospective it's
because i wasn't educated enough i
didn't see all the different disciplines
and how things come together
as time passes and i gained money more
experience i can see that
the more that you you know the easier it
is to do it and
the more comfortable you feel not making
every decision yourself but rather
consulting with the entire team to make
the list definitely okay
ron i have to know what excites you most
so you've done
all sorts of things you've worked at a
variety of places but what what really
gets you excited about
being an engineer and leading teams uh
it's interesting i think the challenge
the challenge is definitely a big one
for me just
starting a new technology especially new
technologies which i know nothing about
just getting into this technology space
learning it
and then may becoming an expert and
eventually
executing and building something that
customers like and
use uh definitely the human
uh part of it so interacting with smart
people
uh finding a way to deliver together as
a team
uh going through some hardships
during the project and finding clever
ways
around it whether it's technical or
human related so
people get frustrated people get tired
during the long execution
and we find a clever way together
and one thing that i enjoy the most is
being super open with the team about it
just telling them my considerations and
trying to make the decision together
um for me if we if we get to a point in
the project where
we feel that we're we reach the problem
and we don't know what to do
and if i can come into the conversation
and just ask questions and the team
decides on the best platform
that that's a that's a lot of
fascinating okay ron
one or two pieces of advice you would
give to any engineer that is starting
their journey whether it's an early
stage startup or an or a late stage
startup but let's say somebody fresh out
of college
you know they they just got their
bachelor's or master's in computer
science they're joining a new company
what should they keep in mind most
importantly
i think one i would say is focus on
building your
core capabilities so too many people i
see are
are trying to kind of race through the
career ladder become and become a
manager and then
get a certain level or or something like
that i don't think
this is the most important thing in the
long term in the long term
actually to build capabilities with big
knowledge across disciplines
i think that's a that's worth much more
and you start to accelerate very quickly
later on
uh that's one the second one is the
world become
became multidisciplinary you don't
becoming an expert in a one-year-old
topic is not enough anymore
so try to experience experience and to
gain experience with
a couple of different disciplines uh
whether it's software hardware it could
be even broader than that
um a third one is and it's related but
think long term don't think short term
and the fourth one
is uh be nice to people making people
like you
eventually the most important probably
yeah
and and going off of that ron why 20
minutes are up but i need to know three
words that best describe you
all right let's see if i can get this
one quickly the most important question
the hardest one all right so i think uh
first of all i'm adaptable i uh things
are thrown my way i'll find a way around
them whether
personally or as a team when we build
things
and second one i would say i'm
nice and kind to people we work together
i'm not trying to compete
i don't hear that often it's so
important though i mean that's it's such
a basic thing no matter what you do in
life no matter
no matter the level you are and the
experience you've had just being kind
and being nice
being humane i totally agree i couldn't
agree more
and third one um
i don't know i i find it it's kind of
like adaptable but i find the password
always i'm very optimistic i i know that
there will be a way to succeed
i love it sounds like the the really
important traits of an engineer
ron thank you very much thank you for
everything uh for all the inspiration
for all the knowledge
and i think this is hugely relevant to
my path hugely relevant
to a lot of the people that are that are
following this show
and and they're also young engineers on
their path and on their journey so thank
you for your time
thank you for having me